do you think I have a type I definitely
have I like him chubby and hairy Oh
interesting what's up guys my name is
curly and today I'm hanging out with my
best friend my dad got a loose we just
finished watching the new movie on
Netflix called always be my maybe
starring Ali Wong and Randall Park in it
his dad helps him find love and I
thought who better than my dad to help
me find love it's looking a little
crusty these days so uh little bit I'm
surprised you two lost touch he used to
be so close how much money do you have
now it's serious a lot of Who I am today
is really because of my dad I always
feel like I hope to be half the man that
you are you are more than that are you
gonna make me get emotional we're a
family with a lot of love so I'm gonna
go up a little bit and you're gonna look
at some videos of some potential dates
my name is Alberto Corona I am 30 years
old as far as what I'm looking for
someone who's very family-oriented if I
can bring you to my crazy family and you
blend in that we are a perfect match
hi my name is Ollie North's I'm 24 years
old I look for people who are a little
bit goofy and who want to try out new
and crazy things and I want to go and
explore and have fun and I don't know
make memories it seems like a nice guy
maybe curly will like him and will keep
him on the list
hello my name is Luis Guevara my dick is
actually kind of boring but whenever I'm
able to to go out and actually have a
date I take it very seriously because
you know I'm hoping that there will be
that one day that does not become more
wow I'm impressed
Luis was it I think Carly's gonna like
him looks like a nice humble guy he hope
I think I found him
I got some clothes I know you found a
date for me
well you might this jacket I think very
jacket super thick cool but too much for
a first date maybe he is I'm gonna like
jump him right away I'm gonna try
something different
Brown I thought a bad shirt how about
this other one I wouldn't focus of the
flower it's a super cute and I look
really good and maybe blue - I look a
little but you know you look fantastic
oh you look amazing I am a little
nervous you think he's gonna like this
he's gonna like you do you have any
advice he's a great looking guy so
you'll have fun great so I'm gonna have
fun good he's hot all right well here we
go hug guy hey hey are you banished a
little bit my first language actually
wherever the languages you speak English
French I took like three years of French
and I like just know how to order a
Python yeah see whatever you learn em
uncle Saul oh there you go Curly's
trying to speaks French do you usually
date a lot I don't date a lot mm-hmm
but I do want today and you know meet
someone that it will be more of a
long-term relationship what's like your
ideal mate with a loaded question
[Music]
Wow I've seen some real chemistry here
my dad like he's like one of my best
friend like he kind of gives it to me
like a friend would when I was worried
about work he was like it doesn't matter
where you start just be good at what you
do be the best and have fun that's close
enough to me you might mean you're any
man have he's just the straight version
of me so tell me why are you like really
passionate about things I have to deal
with Latino identity anything like
language like I want to learn more and
more cool
[Music]
when was your last relationship maybe
two years I don't really remember
I live it up nine months you know I mean
it's not about being a relationship is
more about meeting good people and
having a great connection are you messy
Oh
oh my god Wow Louise is so handsome
well thank you so much for coming here
with me I think my dad did like an
awesome job I would love to hang out
again yeah sure okay I'll see you soon
[Music]
that was a beautiful couple can't wait
to talk to Carly hey baby how are you
what are you doing here
I was watching the whole time the whole
thing yes you seem a little nervous
he was beautiful amazing I don't even
know they came like that Oh Dana myself
whoa don't tell Mom that that was fun
thank you for setting that up that was
really cool I think that you picked
somebody that was dope he was really
cool like he was into family he was
super intelligent smart and open he took
like this the whole time
really good I'm so proud of you I'm
proud of you dad thank you thank you
daddy
I'm proud of you we broke him a long way
indeed okay whoa that day was so much
fun my dad knew exactly how to pick him
he was charming he was smart he was
great I feel like my dad knows me more
than I think he does but go and watch
this new movie on Netflix it's hilarious
called always be my maybe you're gonna
enjoy you're gonna love it you still
have the Corolla what are you looking at
my back seat because we had sex back
there oh my god what do you think that
it might be even smaller and grosser
than I remember hey you better still be
talking about my back seat
[Music]